one of the
things that has been said about Trump's
2024 campaign is that he's going to pick
a female running mate and the names that
keep being tossed around
primarily are
um Nikki Haley in no particular order
Nikki Haley Carey Lake Marjorie Taylor
green and Christy gnome
of those I genuinely have no idea which
is the most likely one of the craziest
is Kerry Lake and Carrie Lake does seem
very desperate to be Donald Trump's vice
presidential running mate and so she is
wasting no time remember that tonight
Ron DeSantis is going to be announcing
his candidacy against Trump in the
Republican primary uh Carey Lake getting
a jump on the character assassination
appearing last night on Newsmax and uh
saying if DeSantis can't even beat
Disney how is he going to beat Donald
Trump
certainly seems to be auditioning for
vice president let's take a listen but
we can't do it half-assed when you pick
a fight with Disney you need to play to
win and so far Governor DeSantis has
been outworked and outmaneuvered by
Disney as far as I know Reedy Creek is
still exists they're still hosting trans
events at their park what is a trans
event exactly this indoctrination is
continuing and they're actually rubbing
it in the faces of American families you
know if you can't beat Donald Duck how
are you going to beat Donald Trump whoa
that's pretty slick as far as a line
goes I think that's the question we have
to ask when it comes to Governor
DeSantis and I think you should stay in
Florida and continue fighting for the
people there and try to finish that that
fight I'd rather see President Trump
who's a deal maker who can make things
happen take on woke corporations and I
know for a fact he gets results there
you go so Kerry Lake coming out and
saying I wonder how long it took her to
come up with that but if DeSantis de
sanctimonious if DeSantis can't beat
Donald Duck how is he going to beat
Donald Trump and she seems visibly proud
of that one so Kerry Lake auditioning
for VP and I actually think you're going
to see an interesting dynamic
where
even the people
that support Trump many of them they're
not going to be willing to do the
character assassination of Ron DeSantis
because big picture they actually like
him this idea that you would love Trump
but hate DeSantis they're sort of two
sides of the same coin so a lot of this
character assassination of one in favor
of the other is quite contrived the
reality is that on issues and positions
and culture War and the whole thing to
the extent that they take positions on
issues most people who like one of these
clowns would like the other that's the
reality and so when you see someone like
Carrie Lake draw these seemingly
insurmountable obvious glaring
distinctions between Trump and DeSantis
they're quite contrived and they're
usually for politically opportunistic
reasons bonus clip from Kerry Lake
she also said during the same appearance
other people are crazy and not live
living in reality which is quite Rich
for Kerry Lake to say who keeps
insisting any day she's going to be made
governor of Arizona the mayor's lost
their Collective mind have they not yeah
uh they're living on planet crazy and I
I don't frankly want to be on that same
planet with them because they well you'd
better find a flight out Carrie because
you've been on the planet for you're one
of the earliest Settlers of that planet
lost their minds you know they'll say
anything it shows you how desperate they
are they're just completely desperate
right now yeah
she seems to be describing herself and
her supporters she has no no ability to
analyze her own situation the mirrors
lost their Collective mind have they not
yeah they're living on planet crazy and
I I don't frankly want to be on that
same planet with them because they've
lost their minds you know they'll say
anything it shows you how desperate they
are they're just all right
um
so Kerry Lake uh is likely to be one of
the
is it is it impolite to say an attack
dog because Trump always talks about
they treated him like a dog uh she is
likely going to be one of the big
attackers of Ron DeSantis this is going
to continue and it will be very
interesting to see the aftermath tonight
in the meantime Trump immediately
jumping to attacking uh Ron DeSantis